much of life here seems to belong to the
past but building the new mosque has
created work for many in tad by me and
the solar panels on the roof pointed to
the future this mosque here is under
construction and it will have solar
panels on the roof and LED lights
Morocco the host of the Climate Change
Conference in this year it's on its way
to energy future the government has set
itself tough goals it hopes to get half
the country's energy from renewable
sources by 2030
that's just 14 years away here reducing
carbon emissions goes hand in hand with
creating jobs and even businesses for
local people it is a mosque built 70
percent by the people of the village and
it is a mosque during construction
during its construction we managed to
dream people to develop their
capabilities might be to be
self-employed people in the future so
this is why for us it is a special
mosque in marrakech just 40 kilometers
away the world's diplomats are concerned
about Donald Trump the US
president-elect has said he doesn't
believe in climate change decisions made
here will affect everyone and could take
inspiration from the mosque in Todd
mommy